If animals were on Facebook, they'd be pretty
stoked about the non-binary sex options out
there.
Hey wild animals, Jules here for DNews.
Humans have spent the last few millennia attempting
to paint biological sex as purely black and
white, and only in the last few years has
that dichotomy slowly blossomed into more
of a continuum.
The natural world, however, doesn't have those
sticking points.
Instead, nature produced so much variation
in animals and insects, that it would be ridiculous
to even suggest that there are only two sexes
out there, or that they can only be one.
For example, some animals are born intersex,
just like some humans are.
That means they possess both categories of
male and female sexual characteristics, primarily
judged by the appearance of testicles and
ovaries, also known as gonads.
Gonads are just any organ that produces gametes,
which are necessary for reproduction.
Some lower animals, such as earthworms or
snails, are inherently intersex, which in
this case is also called “simultaneous hermaphroditism”
this means they have both ovaries and testes.
When they mate they pass packets of sperm
back and forth before putting the fertilized
cells in a cocoon.
Some animals are born with one sex, and for
a variety of reasons undergo, what is basically
a self-induced sex change.
This is called “sequential hermaphroditism”.
A number of fish, amphibians, and reptiles
are famous for this ability, and in some cases,
they’ll change sex just based on social
hierarchy.
The clownfish, for example, is structured
in a social hierarchy with the only female
fish at the top.
If this top female clownfish dies, then the
most dominant male takes her place, and in
doing so, changes its sex to female.
The same thing happens with wrasses, but in
reverse, with a school of females and a male
at the top.
There are also animals that are considered
one sex but show characteristics of another.
In one African game reserve, keepers discovered
a group of female lionesses sporting thick
masculine manes, and producing loud guttural
roars, which these lionesses used to trick
predators and even safari guests into thinking
they were male lions.
According to one biologist interviewed in
Popular Science, these lionesses likely have
an overabundance of testosterone.
This is similar to the increase experienced
by older women after menopause . Kind of like
these lionesses, many older women begin to
display some secondary sexual characteristics
which we more associate with men, like hair
growth and a deeper voice.
Biological sex is a wide spectrum, with plenty
of overlap, loopholes, shortcuts, and just
plain unexplainable weirdness; at least that’s
how it looks to humans.
But, if everyone else is comfortable with
their sex, maybe we’re the ones with the
weird obsession?
If you’re interested in the natural world
you can go outside or stay in your chair and
check it out in 360 degress!
Our newest channel, Seeker VR, has all kinds
of cool stories, including one about weed
farmers in California.
Now we know that human sexuality has a lot
of ambiguity, but could a man have a baby?
Find out in this video.
Thanks for watching DNews and don't forget
to tune in next time.